hey everyone welcome to this react js
full course video
react is a javascript library used to
create fancy user interfaces for mobile
and desktop applications
it is widely used and is preferred over
other frameworks for front-end
development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you are in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react and some of its concepts
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what's in store for you
we'll begin with a quick introduction to
react and then move ahead with react
installation on windows
later we'll look at some of the
fundamental concepts like react
components
props and state
then we'll build an application from
scratch using react after that we look
at a comparison between javascript
frameworks like angular view and react
we're also going to be covering topics
like react.js with node
react with redux and understand what
react native is
we look at another detailed project
using react it will help you understand
the library better
after that we'll understand topics like
react hooks react router and then we'll
conclude the session by looking at some
of the commonly asked react interview
questions
without further delay let's begin
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
forgoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website say
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say cd
[Music]
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react app okay so this command installs
all the necessary react.js modules now
to check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd
my app and npm start they should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components all right
so i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibling let me save it and if you look
at the browser you'll have hello welcome
to simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple html tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create a first functional
component to do that i'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that i'll create a
file say functional component dot js all
right so the first thing we have to do
is import react so i say import react
from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act.component so going
ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
features used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here
now let's define functional component in
our app.js component so here i say
functional com let's compile it and
check our browser here it says this is a
functional component moving on to my
class component it's the same syntax
here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same name and
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
comp one and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp 1 and then again i define it
here class comp 1. let's compile it and
run it and here we go here you can see
hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
here another class the second class got
imported while the first class that was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nitty-gritties of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now say i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
0. so for that i'm going to use another
snippet called r const and here this dot
state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button
the count value has to get incremented
right so we make use of an event called
on click equals this
dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals it's going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this top
state dot count plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i'll change the name
of the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot
state and here i change x to
count now let's go ahead and import it
in our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
[Music]
higherorder.js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component
that's going to be an arrow function
again and within curly braces i define
my class that is class say new component
extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented 2 i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked 0 times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say
purecom.js so here i'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag i'll
display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
i may call it regular component.js and
here i'm going to use the snippet rce
and the message that i want to display
is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply done itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from your component and then i say
import
regular com from regular com.js and here
let's say regular comp name equals this
dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state
and we're going to set the state for
search results to whatever is passed by
the system so the search results are
going to be returned as a callback and
that's what we'll store as an updated
state now coming to the add track method
so let's scroll up and we'll say add
track and this will take the track to be
added let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now
let's talk about the remove track so
that's the remove track function and
that's the track that we want to remove
so let's let tracks equal to this dot
state dot playlist tracks those the set
of current tracks that we have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is not equal to the
track dot id which means this particular
track is not there in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we are going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not
be equal to the track dot id and then
this is where we would want to say this
dot set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making that change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track
is now the remove track in the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks that will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update playlist name which will take
the name of the track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
with v dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot url so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on uh spotify so that's the reason
we'll access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
musical file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject a search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we refer to in the css
file
we have another component called search
results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks will be
bound to this dot state dot playlist
tracks okay so on the top if you look
here we started with defining all the
function declarations in the constructor
then we provided the function
definitions okay that's how and this
that we passed refers to the context of
the current uh component itself so
whatever you put into the app component
or into the respective component those
values will be then passed out here to
these individual functions okay so
that's with the playlist couple of
things we'll have to do is if somebody
changes the name of the track so on name
change is going to be another custom
event where we'll have to call this dot
update playlist name and we also have
remove functionality so to remove a
track we would say equal to this dot
remove track on save equal to this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
uh on track the export uh app will make
this all of these functions accessible
across other components it's very
similar to the public access specifiers
etc that you provide uh in other
programming languages so that's done
we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar
dot js so that's in terms of the search
bar let's start with the css file so
we'll start with first styling search
bar we will say that the display should
be flex flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rem and
margin bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
0 the border should be 1 pixel solid
white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
uh margin bottom so we've got a cotton
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh on input and if the input is focused
so that's the event that we are looking
for and then we would have a button
called search button so on the search
button the cursor will set it to pointer
so that's the cursor pointer the width
we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 dp954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got a font
family let's set up the font family to
the same standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to 0.833
rem correct this and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic uh
css properties so that will add a slight
uh transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we would not want a border on the
button that would look odd so i'll get
rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
uh the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case
if we hover around the button we would
want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import
react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and
we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we just need one variable here
which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot
search so that's the search function and
we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get the value that is there inside that
text box the moment the search term the
user is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates that's the ascii
key code for the enter button so if the
enter is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where we
write our render method that's going to
render the html view and we return the
complete view here so that's the view
now that we want to return let's say
diff class name equal to search bar then
on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function uh we're going
to return a value i shouldn't forget to
export the search bar okay so that's
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this what
we've done is we've written a render
method we've written our div tag here is
where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the pattern tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
had actually written
uh so two things we've completed now uh
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with uh the playlist and
adding applications etc adding tracks
delete removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
that we are creating and that's how the
entire application is now structured so
and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
256. 256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 five is the last paragraph so that's
the hover uh then we have track
information so track information is the
next class that we're dealing with we'll
add the flex parameter first display
flex and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we need a
margin bottom of 0.22
ref finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size of 0.83
rem and a font weight of 300 and a color
as well that we'll add so let's add up a
color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to
the track and we'll move into the
javascript file so let's move into so
let me take what we added in the search
bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removal so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot remove track is
what it's going to map to let's close
this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action uh let's also have the
return here
and we just add up the button and this
is going to add track so you can look at
how the component is completely dynamic
uh in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added this button with
the hyphen is going to remove the track
this button uh with the plus sign is
going to add the track and you can
actually see how simply it was done in a
render action function so the render
action function actually helped
with uh checking that if uh
on the value of the props
and if the user uh depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash information within it we'll
add h3 we'll bind to this dot props dot
track dot name so the name of the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph we will find to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot album so that's what
we've data bound to and then let me add
an iframe an iframe allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we are going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame border is going to be zero
and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove a
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much so let's
just say track
list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we'll need uh in the css
so let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react from react we'd also want
to import
track list dot css
and
we also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot
map create a temporary variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we connect to add up my
base bracket here okay and uh
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is removal and the on
remove will do this dot drop start on
remove so that's for the track removal
and
so we've got our track list
oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
file that takes care of entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a tracked list that
manages a set of track records so the
track is more relevant to the playlist
and then we've got the search results
also to manage once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero four pixels to pixels to
pixels ash
and then uh let's add
a scroll bar
so
webkit
and mozart are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
width is ninety percent
with a margin bottom of two
okay so
forgot to add the hyphen so it's hyphen
webkit scroll bar zero pixel width
and we've set transparent background so
that's that's about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this will be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get a
track list this would be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be search results so that's the
component and this is going to export
out search results so it's accessible
across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results
and on the on add we are going to bind
to this dot props dot on add so we
already have that so that uh basically
completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up uh
the css that we will need uh to add up
to the playlist and i'm just going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's
just the css for the playlist nothing to
do with react again pure css
let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather
let me get this
and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on
name change that's when we'll say event
dot target dot value so we get the
updated playlist name coming to the
render we now need the input
input
is going to be on change equal to this
dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is
what i will add the tracks i'm going to
bind to this dot props dot playlist
tracks so we're going to bind this to
playlist tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll find that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to
spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard uh that's where we can create
a sample application the name of the
application will be musical file okay
and uh we'll say that we are building uh
some kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide uh so we'll
say next
refresh the dashboard so it's
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration
agree with the terms and conditions and
we will say submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh now
there's a client id that is generated
here for my app which is unique so i'll
just copy that up let me come up to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add a new folder called util
and under that a new file called
spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we'll create
is the redirect url or let's call it
redirect uri and that will equate to
localhost colon 3000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we'll equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot href dot
match and we will say this is equal to
access token which will be equal to and
we will give a rejects expression to do
a pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the patent match is crucial here another
constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edge x
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we're going to say
access token equal to comma expires in
multiplied by 1000 then we will say
window dot history dot push state and we
will say access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we
will say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
json response
dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as a variable with a
lambda expression and we'll create a
temporary json object with id and that's
where we want to associate track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name is going to be associated with
track dot name the artist is going to be
associated with track dot artist of zero
dot name the album
is going to be track dot album dot name
and the uri we will equate track dot url
so that completes uh this block will
open the next and we this will be the
save playlist which will take the name
and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we'll create a user id and now
we will return the fetch result where we
will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers
will be the header information then we
call the then function declare response
as a variable use the lambda expression
and access response dot json we use the
then block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 slash users slash dollar of user id
slash playlist so this is how we've
constructed uh the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say
json.stringify to convert this parameter
name and then we will generate a
response variable to response dot json
and then we'll create json response with
the lambda operation we'll create a
constant playlist id which is equal to
json response dot id we will return
fetch
https
api dot spot
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable be constant headers and this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and the
body is going to be json dot stringify
uris track uris and we close this we
close this block we close this block and
we close this block so that completes
our code of course one more thing we
have to do which is export this class
out so export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
here is
the client id that will have to exactly
match so i'll copy this client id and
provide it here so that's the client id
that we actually need and we could also
store it
out here
so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if
the access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which
will go and connect to the spotify
service
by using this client id and it will
allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we'll uh actually
need to start up the application so i'll
go to the terminal and rather let me go
to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000 let's give it time to
run and that's the app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i'm just going to
search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually
gave us
a confirmation link
the moment we tried to connect and
execute our application
that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the
service there and try to return a value
to us so this is what we did we just
added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
music or file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that i'd actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity uh that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole in this session
we'll be comparing the three cutting
edge ui development technologies that is
react.js angular and vue we learn about
the key differences that make them so
distinct all of these technology stacks
have been replacing pure server-side
technologies and we've slowly progressed
from server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and a
part on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the salient features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dom updation
is time consuming risky and error-prone
vue also ensures faster and bug-free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an
e-commerce website as say user one then
you should be able to see the items in
your shopping cart while user two would
be seeing different items in their
shopping carts and so on so identifying
the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now view again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to the act
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for view according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support welcome to this
session on how to connect react.js with
node.js and in this session uh we are
actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express gs application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so expressjs
is a rapid application development
framework that allows us to create a web
application very quickly on the node.js
platform and we'll use it to create a
custom api and then connect that
endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
has now completed and let's uh go and
open up this project so i will say file
and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us uh our startup page the sample
uh default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go and try
to create uh the backend uh application
which is going to be another application
that we will set up and to create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will uh
create an express application on node.js
called api and let's give it some time
for installation okay so that's done
clear this screen we'll come out here
we'll open another instance of the
editor we'll say open folder and that's
the api application we'll say select
folder and the api application is opened
let's go to the terminal now in the
terminal we will attempt to install all
of the packages that are required that
would be logged in the package.json file
so the package.json file here would be
listed uh so you can see we have a list
of uh packages that it uses and npm
install will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request
and the response parameter and next
pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props here i would pass props
to the superclass constructor and set
the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to
dot text and then we will again say this
dot set state api response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a diff
class name as app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step uh
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application
so for that we'll have to install
globally cross origin module and dash
dash save indicates that it's going to
do a global install for all applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cars so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for
localhost 3000 which is the react
application the react application should
go and talk to the api that is hosted on
node.js which returns to me that string
message so if i go and ping that api
separately which is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i directly ping
the api that's hosted in node.js now we
are consuming it through the react.js
application and if you scroll down you
can see the message returned from
node.js into react saying the api is
working properly so the practical impact
of this is to actually host restful
services etc on node as a server and you
can go and consume the data that is
returned there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution uh what redux is what are
the core principles of redux and what
are those pillars that drive what you're
doing redux and then finally what are
the pros and cons of redux and after
we've gone through the powerpoint
presentation here what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go through
and actually do a demo of actually using
uh redux so you can actually see how
this would all look so why would you use
redux well the reason why you want to
use redux is that redux actually
understands and helps manage the state
of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the stage for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be uh
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know take a large application that
you could create with app with a react
and breaks it down to several components
instead of having this massive number of
states you have to manage and so every
time that you you know an application
will then switch from a current with a
react you'd actually be then changing
the state and this is a a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential for applications to be
re-rendered which reduces the efficiency
of your application and so this is why
redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to manage the state of
your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
the application can be described to the
store by the user and then it notifies
any modifications made to the state of
that application so let's jump into the
key principles of redux and there's
three key areas i want to focus in so
the first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth um and that's our
source of truth is being able to store
the state of your whole application in
an object tree in a single store and
this makes it easier for you to debug
and inspect
components of your application it also
enables you to be able to persist your
app stage for development and improve
fastest development cycles the second
principle is a state is read only and
this way you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions have become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this so we can
actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to a previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reduces
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
um and there are four key
states there's getstate which turns the
current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to uh
get the state store from from our
terminal window uh the second state is
dispatch and this is a an action it's
the only way to update the application
state and here we have a action on a
button change to actually change the
state of the application and then the
final two are subscribe unsubscribe
and these are
ways in which you can actually change
the listener to the state
so an action is a plain object that
represents an intention to change the
state so with actions you have payloads
of information that send data back and
forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data and
they can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a type field
that indicates the type of action that
has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are specified how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store and so actions
only describe what's happened but don't
describe the application state change
they are reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make your solution really
optimized as an experience and then
finally developers can track everything
that's going on inside the app in real
time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but the component cells can access data
and they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
and it's set up and it is memory
intensive so with that let's go in and
look at a demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available
in windows mac os and linux you can also
download and recompile the source code
if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node
version it's going to give me the
version number so that shows it's
installed and we also use npm which is
node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm dash dash version so
okay so looking good and we're going to
go ahead and create a folder um on our
desktop
normally you wouldn't put a project
folder on your desktop but you know this
is just for
an experiment so we're going to call
this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being uh taken
through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
uh you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we'll also install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is a react
and it's react.js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
i'll just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we have everything installed
great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code is open source
solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source and uh there's just a ton
of stuff here but we're going to go
ahead and open up the folder we just
created on our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder we're just
gonna get rid of the welcome screen we
don't need that anymore uh you'll see
there's some commands we use we do uh
control plus um i'm not sure what that's
called again anyway it gets us to the
terminal window um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
here on the index.html you see the index
file there and we're going to actually
show what this looks like inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um
uh
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's gonna be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's gonna take us to local host
call on 3000 give it a moment and then
we should get our
floating uh logo showing that the
application's up and running up there we
are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
new
comp dot js and we actually have some
code that we've already created that you
can download as part of this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
dash dash save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here
is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the uh using the store and
reduces in redux
again
the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app
don't forget to save your work as you go
along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
make the italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically use our
style
i'm going to add in a button
click
action
subscribe
and don't change too many s's
save that
all right save now let's run
a script
you guys have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the use called js
component into here
player in
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's very simple little
application
now playing from use call
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm
start and here we go refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and oop
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
it's newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image that
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simplyline hit
subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and essentially reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
and here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
cont store
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and we're gonna
pull in
strict mode
okay juicer is not too fine let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
i'm just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and let's map our state
to props
equals
state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct
map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to be in
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
this
from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we're
actually connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here so serve to
button change we're going to do props
dot button change
otherwise we would be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
i'm going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply that
and then
the
we're
reducer
to place to where the reducer is
and
constant new state
and
it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
it's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then
new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default now we have the new
message
yeah this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start let's see what happens and our
web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just hunting down
errors in your code
so let's go to index.js
and
let's say
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
let's
rerun a
file
and we want to move our file let's just
go ahead and move the store
i'm gonna update all the links to the
store
and we're gonna be providing making sure
our provider
store
[Music]
is referenced correctly
okay let's rerun our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and it's able to then create the new
message again this is a very simple
application but you can see how for more
complex solutions how this becomes
useful and you start using the different
components you create um for your whole
solution
and that's our demo
hi guys welcome to this video on react
native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform
next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides strong
developer and debugging tools with
meaningful error messages so working
with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook stack
overflow is an excellent website with
several developers interacting about
issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform
only developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform-specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform-specific applications
let's look at some of the prerequisites
for building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong hold
in programming concepts like functions
objects arrays and to lesser extent
classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic concepts
like view state props and styling in
react native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters
these created parameters are called
props short for properties now props are
passed from one container to another as
a way of passing data between them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how we can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style
react native uses the conventional
javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed moving ahead to
our last and final section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native welcome
to this session on react native versus
flutter in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be
that at the end you should be able to
decide and make an informed decision as
to which framework is the best among
those available let's start from a
language perspective now if you look at
react react is basically completely
written and built in javascript using
the react.js api on the other hand if
you look at flutter it is basically
written in a very new language called as
start and we do not have uh too many
developers that are skilled on dart
however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with uh an
in-built javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice for
developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses start which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so that really
is the selling point
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to re-learn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with memes tag already worked with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement
third-party widgets and ui frameworks as
well now this is really what allows you
to pick and choose with react native
because uh you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
telerik controls or any other
third-party ui framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the ui components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically is
built and uses javascript out of the box
and that's the reason when you want to
write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well-defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
coming to the community to go and find
out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and a building
web applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of uh developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and
also
react native is part of
github as it's open source it was
released in 2015 and it's because of the
huge community support that it becomes
easier to implement this you have a lot
of confidence as a developer when you
start building on this stack because if
you're stuck somewhere you will have a
lot of help available on the way on the
other hand if you compare that with
flutter you can look at the question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market
it has a smaller footprint on the
community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases uh there again you would see
that react native does a much better job
as compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if uh we
would need to make a decision in terms
of our careers the technology that we
are learning what is the growth aspect
what is the industry adoption and how we
could really
move ahead on our career graphs in terms
of the opportunities market the job
market etc so again getting back to
stack overflow which is the benchmark
for understanding technology trends in
i.t sphere and software development if
you look at a recent survey conducted in
2019 uh 62.5 percent of developers uh
seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg uh you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flutter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not really well
organized the popularity perspective
react native much more popular among
html5 css three mer mean stack
developers since it's all javascript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence has a
stronger community support as compared
to flutter and that translates into
better job prospects in the industry for
react native as compared to flutter so
if we were to give it a score react
scores much better with a total score of
five leaving flutter with a total score
of two so i hope we were able to
understand the differences between the
react native and flutter and this will
help you make better decisions with
planning your career and deciding which
technology you should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so we'll be using javascript
to be installing react and installing
the various components such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see when the
calculator works just fine and now let's
go ahead and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things
and so we go to the default node.js site
and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms uh it comes with a ton of
extensions so you can get up and running
really quickly with it
um so we're just gonna go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to download
it again
you also want to make sure that you have
the latest version of node.js installed
now with that node package manager so
we're just going to open up our terminal
window and validate which version that
we have running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to uh
do that and we're gonna also now create
a react app so we're gonna do install
and then it's gonna be create dash react
dash app that's the command to create a
new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and
it will take a few minutes just to
install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be saved on
the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have uh our new folder right
there
on our desktop but we're actually going
now into visual studio
and if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code
because i can run terminal window right
there so i'm going to open up the folder
that we just created that's called
calculator i want to open up the whole
folder
not a file but the whole folder
and here's our folder on the left hand
side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
which version of react and the dom
and here's our default
uh element
and as you can see because we're using
react it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference
some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to
our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
all right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and
it's now gonna have everything running
on let's have localhost and everything
running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then
bring up just the standard default react
boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so
see now yep everything's running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the app or you can
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
[Music]
there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
i'm putting a default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components
layout you necessarily have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that
so dot upon folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're going to have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we are okay so that shows us that
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
and
put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a
css file that we'll use to create these
elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but
as bottom line is that the calculator
really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on-click command
this is some basic javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete
now we have an unclick event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
making sure everything looks good
and one of things we can now do because
we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just going to find pin
the numbers
7 8
9
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay can get it
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
now
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we're doing our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just going
to pull those over
um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create cse css files and
um you know we'll certainly do that but
i think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the border color et cetera et
cetera
and so i'm going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons we have the css link
back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the result
screen and the
uh default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets from the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
so i'm going to import the logo
we'll import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we'll go to amg which
we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder
but uh in this instance because we're
just putting up a solution i want you to
be able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are how about
simply that logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to go to our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
uh this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and approach row
put our instructions here so we're going
to like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct
our solution
and we're going to update the output
row.js file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field
that will be read only on the top of our
calculator
and here we see our text field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row dot
css we're going to add in our specific
css
for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default um
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
pull in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring our text size for our output
flow here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rows
save that
and
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output and we'll
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you can see they're referring to a
font asset we actually have the font in
there to
pull that font over um and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the result
the you state
the initially state will be just blank
there we are
just what you'd expect to see
so the results
um
are blank and this is just when you run
the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together a
script to do the
calculations so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application
putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images
fonts
css files
laying out our core structure in html
form elements and now um the part that
we're doing at the end here
is putting together the script that will
actually write
that actually do our calculator
events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
there are different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign
and
we have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay it's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which just to reset the screen
and
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands all your variables lining
up
correctly
eliminate those
we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over and this is now this is
our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct and we'll see
that our calculator is working so clear
gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we will restart the services
say yes
i'm running on another porch because we
already have an app running on
another port so it's going to run on
3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
make it a native application as well
right now we're just using as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app
all up and running
hello everybody and welcome you all
so
we're going to talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is once called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens
when we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down okay and we have actually
increased the productivity of our
development
now how the react hook really changes
the way this we're gonna see it now in
those slides
now what are the react hooks see the
react hook is a special feature that
lets you
hook intro
now what is this
see they say few important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
stateful logic without changing your
component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hooks let you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class-based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle management
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards a
state
less or functional component so by
adding those hooks features so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you'll be having some
add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hook only call hooks from the react
function component don't call hooks from
the regular javascript function instead
you can call hook from the react
function component or call hooks from
the custom box so there are multiple
options are available which you can
expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used straight hooks even hooks and
create customized hook and we will see
some demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
gonna start working with another type of
foxy
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
even based hooks we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
props dot
count so my question is like what do you
mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name called
obstacle dot
default props
default
props okay equal to i'm starting with
the curly braces and after this curly
braces here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we're giving count
initial value equal to what a zero now
and uh post this
this value whichever we are giving it so
what we also do in the same line is uh
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way
i can say set count count plus 1
okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was zero
that's why if you see initial value was
zero
so now because of getting the initial
value called props dot count and now i
can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus one and this value
rather than saying count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hopes of an option which
is available called life cycle hooks
life cycle books are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to launch
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it
so are you going to be making it now
let's take a look now so initially what
i'm doing is
i'm just creating a new function called
use
because it is a pre-defined
okay available from
okay react 16
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property
from react and under this use effect
what i will do is i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see this thing called every time
even if i say increment it is getting
called even decremented is getting
called and reset it will get called
because this is a life cycle method
and the life cycle method means it will
get called
normally in a react we have a call
component dead mount and component did
update so it is a combi of both
okay however
you can
stick this particular use effect to the
specific need only like if you do not
want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this square bracket will contain those
values which you would like to watch for
those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what
blank so now if i just go ahead and
start it is saying called every time and
now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now
it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching
not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see the state is getting
changed for this count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it a supply
i hope you are clear about what use
effect is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
straight hook where we have seen use
effect we have also seen another feature
that is called use state and now we're
going to be talking about our next okay
everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as called use
context
see when we talk about react use context
we always have a very special feature
coming up with us where the reusability
comes as in priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem and
then we discuss about the solution so
now here
i'm gonna say
use
context structures and in this use
context.js
what are we doing i'll be creating some
few functions here i'm saying
function
name
okay
so in this main app i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
use state element
and now after this i'm using return
and in this return
with my div tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name called
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise
if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use that's an
important thing i would like to consider
right now so this is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and say
user2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
users in parameter
okay so return
you can define it anything i can say
paragraph
and this i can say
user to
component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here
i am defining this value called
user3
okay space
user
equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where i'm trying to use this
functionality
so we are having this function user2
okay so after this
we are taking function 3 and adding the
data right over there
okay so this dev tag
whichever you're taking it
so we have a called main app we can say
user two and forward per user three so
the data we can keep on passing from one
component to another compound
so we have got this component with me
user 2 and same time we have called user
3 now
okay and this user 2 whichever is
available to me
ok when we are saying hello user
this user 2 i can provide this data
right over here
okay so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay
and with this we can provide the value
called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what we'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user three it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user
three only from its immediate child
which is a user tool
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called mainapp
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
app.js
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin welcome
so that's pretty fine uh components are
basically rendered but there is no
reusability if you see like it is a
plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
tab context equal to
create
context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag
so i'll be using this option i can
use a context
or the context which you have created
that is called app content so we are
saying what
app context here
okay dot
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context
i would like to cut it
okay and paste it after here
okay and here
user to equal user to whatever it is the
value is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
video to the user 3 also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay
so
you say value equal to what
user here
so after that you're saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it
okay and say use
context.provider okay and the second
component
when you say user 2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove
it okay and the same you can remove it
from here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay use ref is basically what the use
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you user x allows
actually to persist the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a re-render when updated
okay
that means
you can persist that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example so you all
can understand how we can utilize this
okay so i'm gonna create another one
here
name call use ref dot
cheers
inside this user.js
so let's get started with this
implementations the one which we are
looking at it now
so called users so once again i am
creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl
comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
prep value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value
black we do not have initial value so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value
okay dot
current
equal to
input val
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
to be get updated so we are passing
input value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i will
be saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
div tag
and here in this dip type we can say
input type
equal
to text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying unchange
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target
dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready i
just want to use the
s3 tag
to show what is the current value we can
say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we are saying
last value of
using
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist
use reference value between the render
so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name of
app
and this app i'm using it here in my
app.js
app
let me terminate it
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
blue color 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome
soon into our system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value when i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value
that's where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you
so everyone we have already seen like
our previous example like how we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in
hook's continuation to this
and that we're talking about called
working with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook which is as same as like
in use state
okay it allows for
custom state logic
unlike
the normal state how we maintain using
new state allows to help
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where if you have a
multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contains a
centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can actually do this
and how we can utilize that so in hoax
demo i'm going to create a new file here
i'm going to give the name called
not
app.js
and in this node.js i would like to have
some initialize state i would like to
make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic call
const
note reducer
node
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like in normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use the
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm using action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
which all the existing nodes are
available populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
const
let's create a states first we are
saying const
nodes comma
dispatch equal to use
reducer and insert this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken it
is an action here and comma the initial
state which i'm making it is a blank
i do not have any states i'm making it
as a blank again i'm using this option i
can const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank
so that's how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically
display the list of nodes back to my
application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of notes how do i do this
so here
let's try to create
the
notes app so this i would to make it
that was the reducer for us
now here we gonna create const
node
tab equal to
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
we can have a number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the div tag
inside this tab tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot
map in case if i'm having a array of
notes map is a predefined function
for me so here we're using what
note
okay so
so inside this we would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so i can use the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
we can just use
the default state which is available
called nodes
equal to what nodes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
the data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
not app and this note up i'll be making
it as a child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here
so in case if i have few more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our god
list of records are available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about what
in case if i want to use
uh you know this reducer so how we can
further utilize it to initialize
the data with this but later on if i
want to some add some actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm gonna tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular tool so what is the
user memo it is again another hook
so
use memo hook return some memorized
value what it was the previous value was
so you can
say think of
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo hook only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function
okay so it is
used memory can be used to keep
expensive and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running
so we will see how this
use memo can work
so let's check this out and see see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
uh calculations so that it doesn't need
to run
every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
except the second parameter
okay to declare it dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
memoir.js
okay so inside your memo app.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say zero
for a time being i'm trying to use now
okay
and uh
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
equal to use state
i'm making it as a what type array type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation
equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set
count c
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to dos here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions we are basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i am having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another tape tag here and here we're
using
my
after this h2 we would like to use
[Music]
index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here here
sorry
equal to what
index here
and here
totals
[Music]
okay
do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
will be calling
add task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another tip tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here and
call something called
calculation
just like a normal message and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done so your dip tag
is also close
both the trip tags are kind of getting
close
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard
calculation okay so let's see what we're
trying to do
so here i'm saying
power running calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button insert this lock button i'm
saying
calculating here and pause this
business call for
let
i equal to zero
i is
less than
[Music]
okay and using what
i
plus plus
and say
num
equal to one
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so
now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay whatever i'm talking about
the long running function
okay will only run when the count is
changed
and not when the to-do's are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we're using this statement
and
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to delete
dependency this exp so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's the whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use impellative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use reparative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends because it allows
again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code
okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
button
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props and second is called what
two parameters we are passing it now
here we are saying
const
user if okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
imperative handler and here we are
passing what refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
customer is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props
we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay
that's it and
once it is done then
we would like to use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application system
so once it is ready i would like to
make it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here we are passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here
i will be making it as a child off but
uh in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
uh i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having we
just said cut
and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yeah
so inside this button using
on click
equal to
we're saying btn
okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here okay so we say
import
button
which class you have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what btn.current.
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the options are
so you understand in this particular
example we have developed a custom
button component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed a button
component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object so button component is the child
component of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called
user defined blur function which is
attached to the pass reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't written anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
under here
okay
so now
okay so
here the things are working the way we
were expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use empirical reference so we have a
call function button
we are passing two parameter props and
ref so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as in the kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const in equal to use reference null
return we are returning this button
one click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur and uh after that is
getting close using f equal to what btn
whichever you're referring it and that's
it so the job is done
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all
loading is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise to block
so the use
layout effect okay works in the same
phase as component mount and component
did update methods we should only use
use effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example the one which you are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're going to give the new file name
called use
layout
okay
and here we're using const
equal to
use the state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this class is saying
use layout is working
okay
with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the value history
okay so we say
return
inside this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
left
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
okay we need to check
[Music]
so
value okay all right so here i need to
use
to make it okay so now i go to the
inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected
used out is working well it is working
to the react it's perfect so that's
where the idea of this particular
example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react based development
so when we talk about use debug value so
what use double value actually does and
what we uh really do with the use debug
value this we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the developing custom books so use debug
value is a simple in-built hook that
provides more information about the
logical of a custom mode within a react
dev tool so react dev tool is a tool
which you can
get it uh downloaded for your chrome
extension okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react
use debug value is basically be useful
for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way
if i just go back and create a new file
and give the name called usable value
use
double dodges
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
and here we can use const
is
online
set
okay and now here we use this option i
can work to use
debug value and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option
return
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
online online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the requiem users
hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing as we know it
very well the routing is synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
you know to be navigate from one part to
another part like you never call login
page registration page and you've got a
lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react networks once again for
mobile-based
environment for react applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
apis so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something
from where
okay it uses the traditional html5
history api which is one of the main
component so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes so
routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate route will get loaded for
you so-called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like
ahrefs how we used in html pages
so
so different
uh from the traditional react replica
application so it is mainly designed
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create reactor so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook
and the router hyphen tutorial is the
name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen outer hyphen dom so this
dependence you need to install post
first
uh i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
down so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router dom is already
there in place
so we would like to start now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder named
components
okay and inside these components
we will create some file name called
login
dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay out of which i want the first
components to be get launched here that
is known as call a landing page so here
i will also create
landing page.js
so let's go back and create a new
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new
functional component so i just copy the
same
and here in login.js we paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted in a portfolio
so you call portfolio welcome to
portfolio
register
register
login we look at user details
okay so we have got these components
with us
i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class based
component here
so
import
react
from react
now
4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this is
the one we call tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on so
[Music]
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect so this has become my first
component which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in a previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable
landing page we would like to create
some more
dependency we are saying import
from
react hyphen router iphone down so we
will be choosing those dependencies one
by one but from there
we want to start working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as we discussed with you that is we
would like to start with the browser
router
okay
so
from this point onwards you would like
to start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here i'll say c small
component equal to
[Music]
okay it's not loading so we can say
import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we work for login so you will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
we would like to say
login
and in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration we copy the same
use this
register
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called logger and
second register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes
that's it
so all this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
go welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
[Music]
portfolio
so
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call a user details
import
name call
user details here
so we got to use the details let me copy
these two
so register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all the registered
successfully
then in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
okay
so within this
you're gonna add
the new
tag call header within this you will be
using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like in two
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register
we also have called
last we have
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
base component when my components start
it should work automatically so i can do
one thing like my login component to be
the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exactly equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's how
your url works
okay everybody so in a previous examples
we have seen how the links are working
but these links are all internal links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link and i'm
clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplydone.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
and i give the name call
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it is asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that'll be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now
so you can see we have a call simply
that the moment i click it
here so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which
we're actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and uh
[Music]
refresh this i click on signal and you
can see now it took me to an external
location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply do
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available like you can see
right now we have got
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more and i say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided let's just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can say simply learn youtube i click
it
you can see it took me two way to the
other
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they are simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature which helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests
to the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called babel which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is uh an api created by w3c and
it creates an in-memory representation
of the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic tom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
tom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of processing time again to debug react
is much more simpler and that's what
makes it more popular in terms of its
simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages are a subset of the
standard and are derived from these
standards to ensure that the code will
execute on all browsers and the code
that we are writing is standards based
so these are the few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 syntax on the top we are
creating a simple react class component
and the render function just returns a
stream of html content in ex6 there's a
new keyword that comes in which is
extends so you are extending from the
base react component and creating a
custom component and then returning a
stream of characters also the function
keyword no longer needs to be used so
the exports versus export also changes
so you use exports to export out class
from a module so that it can be accessed
from another module in es6 you simply
say export and the component require
versus import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standards-based
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an on
click sun another browser would
understand a click and to ensure that
it's consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the lists display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names uh
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we're using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names added to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of uh simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform crud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons check boxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to event
or target dot value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write commands in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the pipe so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of
150cc and to access it if you look at
the import statement we are importing
app from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simplylearn and in the render of
the react dom uh we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply learn
would be the final output and that's how
you can embed one component into the
other using this methodology what are
the differences between class and
functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders
this.props.title the constant stateless
component would be equal to props the
div tag returns this dot props dot title
so you can look at the style very
different in terms of class and
functional components one using the
arrow operator one using the traditional
class and render method so the class
component can hold or manage state
complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any lifecycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
lifecycle methods of components we've
got kennish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
applications state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a rear router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route default out it takes you
to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css
is the extension the css inside a module
file is available only for the component
that is importing it so there are no
naming conflicts so dot button is the
css styling inside button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the
button.module.css file so let's talk
about some introduction to react context
now first important thing we need to
understand
a typical application when we talk about
react application so data is always
passed through what from the top-down
approach
with the help of props as we know it
very well
if we have a component like an a b and c
and if c components wants to get the
data from
a so a cannot directly pass the data to
c because
c is a child of b and b is the child of
a so according to the rule so data has
to be
passed through the proper hierarchy that
is known as drilling down the props
which is one of the very very
complicated area because when you have a
complex hierarchy and if you are making
a lot of middleman in between so this
create a lot of confusion in your
development and hence your application
gets more and more complex
so to avoid such kind of scenarios so we
have this option like in
react context so in context cp what
happens like here
the data can be passed directly
to any of the component whichever
needs that
so data gets stored in a centralized
environment and from there it get passed
down to all its child wherever it needs
whether it is a direct child or it is a
indirect
so this is what the benefit you get with
the help of props here
so if you see the main components have
got not many childs so using the props
you are passing the data to all its
child directly but the challenge here is
that all childs are direct child of main
component what in case if we have
further childs so that create a lot of
trouble
okay so create context is basically the
way where you can pass a data directly
to
the components
and cut down the all middlewares
okay to your applications
and that's what the context api and the
question is like when to use a context
api
so as you can see it is clearly written
like context is basically designed to be
considered as a global state which any
of the components tree can easily get it
directly from its parent
okay without involving any of itself
directly
now
you see like here we have a call app
component which have the language as a
function
and here we have a call select language
so you are passing the data here to its
child
okay so you see here the language
component needs to take a very important
extra component that is known as call
what lang
and pass it to the selected language so
this could be further painful or more
complicated when on every single button
if the app needs to know the language
and what it is pass through the other
components so we want to basically cut
down all
so context api we want to use it
okay with using this areas like a
react.create context
so this create context helps you
to create a context in a parent
component whichever you want and let
other components subscribe to this so
whenever the changes are happened
they would be immediately informed about
that so here we have a call provider
so here every single context
okay so comes with a react
provider so they are basically trying to
consume the state
whichever is being available with the
context
so using this property like in class or
context type you actually consume the
nearest current
of the context with using this dot
context
now we will call consumer
so this particular component which is
actually subscribing to the changes
okay so this let you
basically subscribe to the context with
a functional component and here you have
a call context or display name it
basically accept a display name as a
string property
okay which you can easily drag through
when you talk about react dev tools
now let's talk about a demo
of our development
so now here let's get involved on the
demo part
but before that i would like to show you
one simple problem statement which you
feel it so this if you see there we go
context api which is available here so
here you can see this is
a property drilling where you are called
parent you have further childs and your
further childs so the component
properties that keep on going through
multiple mediators
which you want to avoid
okay and the right hand side if you see
this one is basically the parent and
immediately passed on to it with child
and you see like here it is happening
this is the wrong approach where the
data is basically going in the waterfall
model
this is better because here the data has
been passed from parent to any other
child directly
so that's what the benefit you get it
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about some
quick demo so that it can help us to
understand how we can utilize this react
context api for our development
so here
uh this is my project which is there
already developed
in my browser
i just when i open up i see here in
local 3000
i'm getting this as a welcome message
so nothing fancy let's get started with
creating a new component i'm creating a
new folder
the name called
components and insert this i'm going to
create a new file
and give the name anything whichever i
want i say
index
dot
js or else i can use some different name
called
main app.js that looks fine
well here i need to import
okay
import
react from react
well let's go back and start developing
a function so i'm developing
function
app
because i'm talking about functional
component
return
div
within this tab tag i'm using this h2
tag
and now here we are saying
welcome to app
component
okay so that's a just a basic example we
have it
going ahead i would like to add few more
components like
function
imply
and the same thing
return
and here once again
okay
and here once again i'm saying h2
welcome to
employee component
okay
so
like this i can copy
and have one more that is called
salary and i'm saying
welcome to salary component
so these are the basic component sets
which are available to me
now certainly you will be having some
parent
and
employee
here
i would like to make
okay
that means employees are comp child of
app and
salary is a child of employee component
okay so it's very very simple
and straightforward
and later on
i can have
the new component ready in which i can
deploy
this
and make it available to the
end user
okay
so let's see what i'm having it now
so
here we have a call app
and here we are saying um
finally
equal to
i just use the name called main app
that looks more better
mainer
and here we are using
react
dom
so we want to basically render it
wherever you want it
so what else what we can do is on the
other side
we can say
export
default
main app
we can do like this in this menu i can
add it under my
app.js file
so it came from here and let's check
well i got this message printed here
so
this is
very simple and straightforward like you
in creating a parent and child
relationship so now
the actual job comes
when my application is having
some of the details which i'm looking at
it
okay that means i want to have a data so
as i said earlier that when you are
creating
the react-based component so you need to
have some
relationships where the data can be
stored in anywhere so in the next
example i will show you how to store the
data in the main and how we can pass it
to the others
now we will be providing the data to our
main component
which is my main app
so here i would like to provide
const
here we can have
because we're talking about state
management
so we're saying employee
employee
equal to
use
state
use state
and here
in our use state will provide some of
the important information like an id
suppose i say one zero one
and i say name
and i can just give the name called
admin
and uh
so we have a call id we have a con name
let's try to
[Music]
put it
okay
it has to be here
yeah id
name admin and now we're talking about
location
we can say pune
and
let's talk about
salary
and we can give any satellite
like one two three four five so
here we have got this uh quick
state which we have created
okay so the next thing is like once your
state is ready
okay so you have to provide some input
through which the data can be available
to the others
and to make this possible
here
above this we are providing
const
employee context
equal to
react.greatcontext
so we are initializing our context
to confirm
what we're really doing this now
and in this context whichever i'm having
it now
i would like to provide a data which i
can easily access to my other components
so now here once i provide a context
here
okay so when i see this welcome to this
component you can see we have called
employee available
yeah so what i will be doing is now here
we will be saying
employ context
using employee context
dot
provider
okay
now here
we want to provide
we close this
yeah so here we are providing value
value equal to the value object so what
value object we are having it right now
here
that is called employee
so this is state we are initially
providing it here
and
this
area wherever the context is basically
available we'll be providing this
employee object and pass it within this
so this employee object which we are
having it
so now you can see the context is closed
here so now within this context we have
passes employee so the all data will be
available to this employee object now
and that's the best part of this code
now
okay now this context i can easily get
it
in my employee
okay
and access all the details whichever i
wanted
now if i see here
i can come down and i say
let
context
equal to
now we are using this option i can use
context and inside this use context we
are talking about
employee context so we got the details
whatever we have set it on the top
okay and here
i can set the details like we are saying
welcome to the employee component so we
have got a lot many things available
here so
label
so let's provide a details here
so we are saying employee id
colon
here
we can use the details
okay by saying
context dot you can see we have got
details available
like an id
likewise i can just copy it
paste
it employee name
and call employee name
so we also have a part of this
id name location so we can also pass
location
okay so we have got those
details available with us
and in a similar line
whatever details we have taken it from
there i can also pass it where
in my salary component too where i can
display the salary related details into
my code so like here i can just copy
this here
okay so we got employee context which is
available
and here i can provide the same number
of amount
like but this time
i may require sorry
i may require the name
as well as the salary both
okay
so these two details
whichever you want you can easily get it
and make it available to the client
okay so this using use context
you're actually trying to retrieve all
the relevant information which was
required and you can see it is available
here so the same employee which is there
now i can have this employee details
under my employee component and under
the my salary
we have a call salary component so
that's something which makes
your context api more interesting
because this is where
you avoid bringing any middleware and
make this data
or component easily accessible outside
welcome to this video by simply learn in
today's session we're going to learn all
about node.js so without further ado
let's begin and look at what's in store
for us first up we'll understand what
exactly node.js is then we'll understand
the necessity of node.js then we learn
about some of the parts of node.js
node.js express framework node.js use
cases and finally we'll look at some of
the industry trends so what exactly is
node.js now consider a scenario where a
user interacts with the web application
the user only interacts with the front
end of the application but there's a lot
of work that goes behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the front
end is developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop io
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dal in 2009 and at the same time of this
session its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on google chrome's v8 javascript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution
note package manager has around 50 000
bundles for developers so whatever
functionality is required for an
application can be easily imported from
npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
javascript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use require
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application nodejs
application has many modules to provide
basic functionality needed for a web
application some of them could be http
util fs url query string stream and zlip
next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
javascript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to std out that prints standard
output messages and stdr to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now node.js is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
cluster can be added to an application
in this way here is a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings etc some node.js global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is the directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
nodejs applications experience four
types of errors we have the standard
javascript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by zero now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you
next up we have streaming a stream is an
abstract interface for working with
streaming data in node.js streams are
objects that let you read data or write
data continuously there are four types
of streams first one is readable these
are the types of streams from which data
can be read writeable these are the
types of streams to which data can be
written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is the debugger node.js includes an out
of process debugging utility accessible
via a v8 inspector and built-in
debugging client this node.js debugger
is not feature packed but supports
simple inspection of code it can be used
in the terminal by using the inspect
keyword before the name of the
javascript file in order to inspect a
file say myscript.js you can use the
following method
now that we are familiar with all the
major parts of node.js let's go ahead
and learn about the node.js express
framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
node.js that helps manage the server and
the roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the wear express now
this is used to import express framework
into our node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is eight zero eight one and variables
host and port will contain the address
and the port respectively lastly we have
the console.log which is used to show
the address and port in the command
prompt so this is what the command
prompt would look like and finally the
output is displayed on the web browser
having learned about the express
framework now let's move on and look at
the node.js use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is it's basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js with
asynchronous i o and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
io which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service healing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were asynchronous i o quick
iterations and active open source
community as mentioned earlier
asynchronous io permits other processing
to continue before the transmission has
finished now quick iterations now
node.js is continually being updated and
added new features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
community resolves many problems that an
organization may face in a particular
scenario next up we have nasa now nasa
is an independent agency of the united
states federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as aeronautics and aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have paypal now
paypal is an american company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js for the
fact that node.js has extremely fast
build times it allows tasks to be
carried out with fewer lines of code
when compared to other server
technologies like java and php and
node.js being data intensive efficiently
handles a large amount of data next up
is medium medium is a popular online
publishing platform developed by evan
williams and launched in august 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a data-driven
applications now these applications are
ideal for being interfaced with node.js
servers b to run a b tests now a b
testing is essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis is used to determine which
variation performs better lastly node.js
server maintenance is simpler than its
counterparts moving on to the last topic
of this session industry trends now
node.js developers are in demand across
the globe since many companies are
adopting javascript libraries according
to forbes it is one of the top 10 most
in demand jobs according to node source
the total number of node.js downloads
increased by 40 in the last one year the
use of nodejs in production has
increased dramatically since its release
in 2010. with early adopters such as
linkedin paypal and netflix among others
node.js has seen an exponential increase
in its use in web development the
popularity of node.js is also accounted
to javascript now since javascript is
the most popular language as evident
from a survey conducted by stack
overflow in 2019 many developers can
start working on node.js library with
not much of a learning curve node.js
developers are being offered better
salary options than other web technology
developers according to pay scale the
average salary of a node.js developer in
india is around 6 lakhs 13 000 rupees
per year the average salary of a node.js
developer across the united states is
around 105 000 us dollars per year in
this video we'll help you install
node.js on your windows system so
without further ado let's begin the
first thing you need to do is download
node.js from their official website
so go ahead and type
download
node.js
navigate to their official website
and here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with nodejs which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes so to do that type
in the command
npm
install
npm
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what vs code
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
var
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method so let's go ahead and type
the code
say http
dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080 so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed so
let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based model along with
the javascript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client and the server it's
good to have these kind of standards
where you're not using something that's
unique to a specific framework or a
specific technology this just makes it
so it's a more accessible for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers around
the the concept of the event loop and
the event loop has a a an event queue an
operation completed and fire requests
threaded pull and then it'll actually do
the actual computation or the file
system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework uh such as
angular
on the client and that will then send a
request to the website and there's many
ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual uh request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
cueing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the threads
within a pool so you have the cueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pool which manages those um
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually they're going to be
interacting with a system and that could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server
but then it's also interact with things
outside of its own server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling uh
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with the threaded pull and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pole is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is
so npm itself stands for the node
package manager
no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through um online you
can go to search.nodejs.org
and you can find all of the packages and
modules that are out there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal uh line utility that
allows you to install those packages so
you can actually go through and you can
see the version management and
dependencies that within those packages
and you actually can control the
packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks
big fan of lego and
what's great about lego bricks is that
they're all individually by themselves
very small very specific functionality
but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together you
can build like crazy cool things so
think of when you're working with the
node package manager itself is that each
of those individual pieces that you're
working with
each of those individual packages are
their own lego bricks and by themselves
you can then edit and update and
maintain that piece um separately from
the whole environment as long as your
inputs and outputs they are really the
piece where you snap the lego in or when
you connect lego to something else um
are interacted and open and well
documented then you can actually then
use those modules effectively throughout
your project
um so you can actually then be able to
you do that you can do version control
on your codes and dependencies you can
do testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the mpm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager uh but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window on your your data server
or on your server phone or in via the
cloud
if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that uh code as well
with the installers which allow you to
get up and going very quickly
uh you want to be able to run the
installer and accept all the default
settings uh just uh you know to begin
with you want to kind of have the
standard setup so that you are most
familiar with the normal settings before
you start getting to the point where
you're a master and you're tweaking
things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and once you've actually installed
node.js and to verify that it's actually
installed you can write command node
dash dash version and i'll show them
pull out the version of node.js that you
have installed and then you'll be able
to see that you've got it you're
actually up and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files if you're new
to this space json file is a structured
file format that's based on javascript
it's a very xml like format for being
able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms that you know really kind of the
the heart of each package you create
um it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object and then
it provides a root directory to any of
the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
um in addition and it has any other
additional um information about the
project that adds such as dependencies
and other files that need to be included
so here we have is an example of a
package and that would be created
using npm json script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here um and use um
the command npm in it and it'll actually
run this package and so you would
actually have it a demo application up
and running really quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want to
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using mpm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files
and then finally i'll actually have a
text editor in this case i'm using vs
code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
code that's been created
by npm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move
into
i'm going to do
change directory
i'm going to
the project folder
and we'll see down here that we have an
empty project folder um but for this one
i'm actually going to go ahead and i'm
going to create a new directory in this
one and i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simply lamp folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simply lan
folder uh there's nothing in that right
now so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with npm now to do
this you will have to already installed
npm if you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version and that will actually tell you
what the version of npm you have
installed is it also verifies that npm
is installed so i've gone ahead and i've
been able to validate that i have npm
installed so what i'm now going to go
ahead and do is i'm going to initialize
this folder so to do that just do npm
init and you'll see that the path is
that we're already in the simply lab
folder and then when you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and i
can show you how we can edit those in a
little bit uh we're going to go with
just say yes to all of these just by
hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do we want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update uh
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working
with npm
and the reason why you're using npm is
that you want to take advantage of
packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
uh web applications similar concept
to angular or react.js
i like using it and it's also a great
way to be able to show how we can
install this using npm so to install
this uh you just start with the command
npm and then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above
we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now a dependency it's written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use
express we can actually just come in and
we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops
did i typo that let's try that again npm
uninstall
express
and a couple of things going to happen
one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see um that we can
easily add and remove packages
uh so let's just go ahead and i'm going
to install express again so
install
express
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that will often
happen is that when you're working with
a package the actual json package so
you'll receive
this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
uh install of the um sub modules that
come with it so and you can go through
you can manually install them like this
or you can actually run an install
command so you can actually install all
of them at once i can just show you what
that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
stream
and we're actually gonna go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to
our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just express but
we'll also see that bootstrap has also
been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if you want to
we can actually go in here and we can
say
on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a setup for a base
initialization of your
package going through to creating the
first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for
the package how you then put in
dependencies such as express and
bootstrap how you can install them and
remove them and actually use do all of
this through command line if you have
any questions please let us know
so let's kind of jump into the express
js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and build both web and mobile
applications just a really great tool um
you know i use it all the time for
building up my own applications
um the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so
it's not going to be as have all the the
functionality that you would have in
maybe a larger scale http service
but with that said it does come with a
lot of functionality that allows you to
not only create websites but you can
also do apis and other routing calls
very very nice
so let's go through some of the features
that express js have
so as i mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
that can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
it also allows you to do middleware
requests and responses so for instance
if you want to do an api
and have that be part of your middleware
you can actually set that up real
quickly in fact in the demo that we'll
do later on we'll actually be building
out four different api calls that you'll
be able to do and you'll be able to see
how you can use express.js for that
um and that in then turns allows you to
be able to uh see how expressjs can help
manage some of the routing of the
different
http methods and that you'd be using via
url
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to uh dynamically test the
work that you are developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away and express js have it in
a single packet and then once you get to
a certain point you can then check in
the whole packet um even have it as part
of your container um and then check that
into your
main
project
and then if somebody else wants to then
take on the work they can then just pull
that in
so let's kind of go step through you
know a basic example so here we actually
have a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js
defining the ports it's going to run on
as well as a basic piece of code so the
first thing you want to do is actually
go ahead and define how you want to
install express.js and this is called
the very first variable which is
requiring that express be installed as
part of node packet manager
npm will then pull in the latest version
of express if you need to define a
specific version of course you can do
that
in this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it installs onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello
world will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the
server is going to listen and listen to
port 8081 so that's what that function
entry there defines
and then you can either put in
the a specific host address um in the
demo you'll actually see how we define
that for localhost but you can actually
then point this to a production host
environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a
script to your terminal window telling
you that which port and which host that
you are listening to so let's see what
that would look like so here we go see
have our terminal window and we're
actually able to then
run the hello world js script that we
just wrote and then once we do that
it'll actually then post that we have an
example app listening at and here we
don't have a
web domain address and we do have the
port 8081
and in our browser window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump over and do a
demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.js installed so
we're just going to do a google search
to let you know where you can find
node.js it's actually at
nodejs.org so we select that link that
will take us to nodejs.org and there are
two types of downloads one is the
current download which has
the latest features and then there's a
more stable version that if you're new
to node.js i'd recommend you to download
next we want to find a text editor and
we're going to go with visual studio
code or vs code as known it's an open
source solution from microsoft that runs
across all the leading platforms this
will default to our windows platform but
you can run it on mac os and linux as
well i really like it it's a great code
editor it comes a lot of extensions and
it's open source
next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called postman
again open source and so you can go out
and go to postman.com
uh top right hand corner you'll see a
bright orange download button where you
can actually go and head and download
and install postman and that will allow
you to be able to access
all of your apis that we're going to be
creating in express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up
vs code and we want to go ahead and open
a new folder where we're going to have
our project we're going to just for our
demonstration here we're going to put
this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it will work fine
here i'm going to create a folder i'm
going to title the file the node express
and we'll select that folder that now
becomes the root folder for our project
in
visual studio uh we don't really need
the the welcome
screen anymore so we're going to get rid
of that
and one of things that is great about
working with vs code is you can actually
have the terminal window up and running
as well so let's go ahead and open that
so it's running at the bottom of our
screen and this gives us a little bit of
space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder in
actually into a project running node.js
so we're going to use npm in it and
they'll actually initialize the project
we have another video that explains how
to use npm or node package manager and
you can go ahead and find that um in our
library here but as we go ahead and we
do that you actually see that it will
create the default package
json file which has the
name of the folder is the default name
of the package but you can actually go
in and edit any of these documents
we want to create a default
file that's called index.js
this is where we're going to write most
of our scripts that allow us to work
with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install express and
we'll use the note packet manager to
actually pull and install express
and you can default to specific versions
of express if you want and we're just
going to go with the latest one so we're
just going to put in express and then
we'll go down into terminal window and
say npm install
save express and this will install
express so we can actually test out the
code we're working on and let's take
just a moment to install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we finish
with our package here we can actually
wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
you can see we actually have all the
modules installed you see that we
actually have express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app
listen
to port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our local host
which is uh http server running on
this test machine and we're going to
have express for this project
run on port 3000
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually post into the
console um window a
piece of text saying server started on
port 3000.
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file
a lot of control s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry yeah
it's localhost column3000
and you'll see nothing has been reached
that's because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
nodeindex.js
and hit return and as you can see now we
have a message in our console window
that means that yep there we go we
actually have everything up and running
so we can actually see that the service
is running not a very pleasant message
so let's go ahead and change that
so let's change that to
app get
and
require res
and so if you use the get message that's
change
what will print
and we'll type hello
there
exclamation mark
and we save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happening yet because we
didn't run the script let's go back in
and we'll run the script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message
right well let's actually start building
some apis in this environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull
content so we can actually
create a new file called users.js
and we're going to create
i'm going to go ahead and create a a
user json packet and a jsonpacket is
essentially
a
an array um
consider it like a small database and in
this array we're going to have four
objects each object is going to have uh
three pieces of metadata we have an id
name and email and they'll be
id one two and three and then you'll see
that the names will be
john smith and
we'll make up a couple of others i'm
just kind of giving them arbitrary
email addresses
it's just for our
let
demo
grab this copy it
kind of speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need
one of the things that's nice with
working with a visual studio
code vs code is there's lots of plugins
and so one of the default features is
that if you
select a variable you'll actually look
for the same variable in the script so
you can if you need to you can actually
change them all
once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating
a json packet so we have four items
id one two three and four
for john smith and jack and chris
all right so that's our
array string
and we're going to then make sure that
we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our script
it'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file and we're just going to go ahead
and we want to
like
store where
the the api is going to be so we're
going to create a
folder called routes and then a
subfolder called api
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say
in this instance express is required
for our scripts
and we're going to also say that router
within express router
correct
naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to create a value later on
that will have a unique id so we're
actually going to
pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install um unique identifiers so we
use node package manager to install
uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can go from nothing to something very
quickly
with exp
nodejs because we installed express we
installed uuid and we're off to the
races
so let's have users require the path for
where
our api is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic get
which will be to pull the records and
we're going to have it pull
all the records so router.get and we're
going to require it to pull all of the
records in the json packet that we
created
so there should be four items to come
back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our adjacent packet
and
yep everything looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out
this function here from just a generic
get with a generic
statement to
actually being able to pull in the users
so
we have to go
app
use express.json
dot use
url encoded
extended
false
and dot use
api
users so
you're going to be pulling them all from
the same location
require
and where we have our api
scripts
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
postman because we're going to actually
use postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results
won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so postman again is just a api
management tool if you used apogee or
other similar tools that are on the
market mulesoft um you'll see it's very
consistent again this is open source
and
what you want to be able to do is you
can actually go
and actually go to the path where the
api is stored and then you can use all
the different types of commands within
your
environment to be able to you know test
out the script so let's go ahead and
create a
new project a new request and we're
gonna go with the default get but
there's actually quite a lot of
different commands we can use
and these are just http commands
and we're going to type in the request
and in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
script i think we're good
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay
so we want to run our script so let's do
node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
api
localhost colon 3000
slash api
users
when we do
that brings back
the
json package with our four entry points
there there's all four of them
so that's your
first action now let's kind of get this
a little bit tighter let's actually go
in and see if we can filter by id
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
route
and then we're going to put in the
filter and in this instance it's going
to be id
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the
end of the url string we just had and
put in a number or a unique identifier
and then that will actually then allow
us to pull in that unique record
okay
that's the data
okay so i have
i'm going found
[Music]
take the json and
print it
so we're going to filter here against
user id
and then
publish the results
else
if it doesn't work then we'll just have
a
generic
error message
we should see this though in the demos
we're creating
this is just
good practice
so save that
and let's go ahead and rerun
our node index file against that
folder
and now we can actually come in here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record
and we could change that to 2 or 100 in
this instance and if it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's get so we've been able to pull
all the records we need to filter
against one specific record against a
specific parameter in this instance it
was id so let's go ahead and create a
new user so that what we're going to do
for this is we're going to use the post
command from http to actually push and
post data into
the
data source the data sources are
jsonpacket which means that we'll have
to then push a new record into the json
package using our array statements
because json is just essentially an
array
and so we're going to
post and when we do this we have to
create a unique id so this is where we
have to reference the uid i'm going to
do a v4
unique id
which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email we'll post
okay looks good
okay so
if
new user
i'm going to put dot name
and
new user dot email
and then we want to return
the results
okay
all right and so users
dot
push so
we posted which is a http statement and
then pushing into the
the json packet array
okay
okay it's looking good
all right so
i think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
nodeindex.js
that allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to
the url i'm going to change the http
statement to post
and
get rid of that go back to users now if
we just do this
nothing's gonna happen so we actually
have to go in and we have to update the
body
and this would be the content that we
passed through and we're gonna go
through with a raw
statement here
and we do json this will be
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we want to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an id because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
staff and her email address is steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique id at the top
and then we have name and email which
are the ones that we just created for
staff and staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing you
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an id
and then be able to update the content
and for that we're going to use the http
put command
so we'll use id as our way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so
construct found
of course
users
and
then whatever going is
user's id
so we know how to get the correct record
and then pass the record back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so if failed
i'm going to update
the user
and i'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser id
then pass
the integer
okay
so this is our values to pass against
the id
and in this instance make sure that
we're updating the values of
username
so if we are
updating user
and we're just updating the username we
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the id so it's
going to remain unique and consistent
okay i'm going to make sure that
everything is pushed to the
json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the json
package
okay
all right so we'll run that script again
and looks good let's go to our folder
let's change the http
post let's put it as get
just so we can see that we have
uh all of the values in the array from
the jsonpacket
and now we want to say put which allows
us to
update just
one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll select it1 so
we have one record we can go ahead and
for name we can change this
so let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final api that we're going
to create
is to delete an account and in many ways
it's actually a very basic api because
all we're doing is we're grabbing the id
and then we're saying that all the
associated records with that id
um within that row
as it were in the table just to delete
the whole row
and so
we want to use
again our id as
the unique value that we're
playing against
so we're going to if users are found
and we're going to
filter those users
i'm going to do that filter against user
id
pass that
and
then go and
post a message to our jsonpacket saying
user
deleted
a
generic message if things fail
okay let's save that and we'll
see we'll go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
and we're going to do it by filtering
against a unique id
and then you will then just
eliminate that record
and pass the message that has been
the account has been deleted
okay so save that let's go run our
script
node index.js
good okay has come over here and
we're going to
show that we can pull any of the
accounts so let's just take one of them
one that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the http command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do
one
when we do that it'll actually delete
that record and here we are um it says
that the user has been deleted and we
now only have
three records in the json packet
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to
uh pull all the records from a json
package we'll be able to create a record
update a record and delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our json package that we created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array
and then we have our index files which
identifies what are the apps that need
to be installed and where are the apis
going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
the port
3000 um again these are additional tools
that we need to make sure and that we
have up and running um in our script and
so the first script was to get all the
um the records the seconds to filter
against a user id for just a specific
record and then for creating a record we
actually went in and we used the uid
tool to create a unique identifier and
then we posted in the data for the new
records we did something similar with
updating the record we didn't have to
update the user id we just had to update
the values in
the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all
apis that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become
more scalable
and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful api
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we're going
to start with node.js so let's do a
google search on node.js and you're
playing that
node.js is at
nodejs.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
there's the stable version and then
there's the latest version i'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in windows mac awares and
linux as well
and if we go to the next piece of
software we want to go ahead and install
the text editor of your choice
i'm going to use visual studio code vs
code it's an open source solution it
works on all leading platforms uh works
really well i like it a lot microsoft
did a good job with this i also really
like it that it's open source but
there's lots of extensions you can get
for vs code so it's a great text editor
and we'll also need postman postman is a
tool that allows us to be able to view
the apis that we're going to create so
let's go ahead to postman.com and again
it's another uh solution you can
download for free and so we're gonna go
ahead and select the download button
and it'll automatically detect which os
you're on so in this case it's gonna be
windows but you can also get mac and
linux as well so we'll go ahead and
download those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest api and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created uh we still have the vs code
welcome screen we get rid of that we
don't need that anymore so
let's go ahead and one of things i like
with vs code is you can actually toggle
the terminal window so let's go ahead
and open up the terminal window so we
can actually run that at the same time
and so we're going to
move our cursor to the folder we just
created and there we are you can see
that
and what we can do now is we're going to
initialize this with no package manager
to make this a package
and it's going to go ahead i'm going to
ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these
yep enter
and
enter
enter and turn
and turn and is this okay
yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if you want to
no need to for this exercise but you may
want to for the solution that you're
putting together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js
and this is going to be the reference
file that's in the json package
for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have
for this to run so we're going to
install express and express
is a web service application but it's
very flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install
save express
this will install express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of express you can if you want
to um specify a specific version of
software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expand the node module we
can scroll down and indeed yep there we
are we see express has been installed
along with some other
pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece
and the next
is we're going to define our app and our
app is going to
use express
and we want express as a local host on
our local machine on port 3000 so we've
identified port 3000 as the default port
for our application
and
we are going to now create
a an array
for some movies
and we're going to have id title
director and release date
exception great movie
and director christopher
nolan
and that was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're going to do and a couple
of items here and just so that we
have some more than one entry in our
array and array is a javascript
uh you can think of it as a very simple
uh table now it allows us to have
structured data
uh you can also do a json file you can
also connect to
a database mongodb or something like
that
2019.
okay so we have two movies in our little
array
maybe more than enough right now
a key part is that we have a consistent
structure for the array of id title
director and release date
and so we're going to
create
two
apis one is going to be a get api where
we'll get the list
of the items in our api and the second
will be a post where we'll be actually
pushing in a new item so let's go ahead
and start with the get and what we're
going to do is we're going to select get
slash movie
and
we are going to have this run as an api
and so
what we'll do is we will test this in a
moment
uh this will be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably open
up the postman and run this through
postman so
okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another um
get in a moment will filter by movie id
but let's just get them all for right
now
and we are going to
listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be port 3000
and
we already had defined the port as a
variable earlier and which
so we're just referencing the variable
and the port number is the step the top
in line four
just a text string that's going to get
put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index.js
that runs the script
and tells us that we're listening on
port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into postman
and
grab the data from an api
so here's postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis i strongly encourage you
to have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command and we've done any
applications and web applications you've
probably used get and post
for
the data um that you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle
so we want to go ahead and we're going
to go and
grab get i'm going to type in localhost
and
it's going to be colon 3000
slash
movies because that's the
the name of the
file
and we hit send and
what we get as a response
is
the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array and the data values have been
pulled back by postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie
to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the
post
command
and get and post our http
commands
and so we're going to use movies
and
in this instance
we're going to
push the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we're
going to need
a structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in there the body
and then we're going to
push to
the log
our terminal window
and
push
so here we're using
push
and that's a term in for arrays within
javascript where we push the data into
the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array if you're
new to arrays with javascript i strongly
encourage you to
learn more about them there's just an
awful lot you can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and we don't save it it won't show up
and then we're going to re-run
the
nodeindex.js file
you'll see this we've created here
already
a an api that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the
header from being get to being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so we're going to select post and
then what we want to do is the
value inside of the body
and so let's go over
and we want to select body
and select json so it's going to be
structured
and so here we will essentially copy
the structure we have here so let's go
ahead and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an id because we
don't have an auto generated id so we're
going to make this id
3
and then
and it's going to be a number 3
and then you want to put in
title
new movie
i'll put in
director
[Music]
and
we'll have this as
i don't know
new director
not very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore dates
let's just put in a date
uh today's date will be fine
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the datecon
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
boom movies been added to our list
and we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and
now we go to below
oh looks like we put an error in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the
json and we will pass it using express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use express json
express
url encoded
extended
false
and this should help us pass
our
value
and then we'll rerun that script
make sure you save the previous file
otherwise you won't run the new script
all right looking good so let's go back
and
let's go back to
our
localhost 3000
slash movies
and there's only two values here
so what we need to do now is change from
get to post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw jason
and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
json packet
into
our array
we actually just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's
remain same so let's go ahead
and
[Music]
get everything consistent
and we change the number to three
and creating a unique title badging i'm
sorry new typo it doesn't need to be
unique just the id needs to be unique
so title new movie
director change it to new director
now change the date
i'm not doing any formatting on the date
so if i'm getting any date
any number really
hit save
movie has been added to our list
so it's been added but now let's go back
to get and let's see if we can actually
see the third entry and scroll down
and there we are we've actually pushed
that
json package into our array
so we now have three items in the
opening added fire our api
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search
our movie database i guess we only have
three entries but you know we want to be
able to so we can do that by using the
get command
and what we'll be doing is we'll be
validating against
a specific id number
so we have three
and we're going to
validate against
just the id number
in this instance um the way to do it is
through the url so beforehand we had
localhost colin 3000 slash movie now
we're adding in uh slash movie slash and
then whatever number of that will
actually filter against the id
and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into f movies
dot id again we're using the id value to
actually pull from our arraylist
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a json
packet
and
if we have any errors then what we'll do
is we'll throw up message maybe not
found so
there we are we're going to pull against
an id
and we should be able to then pull that
up
through postman
into
our terminal window
again the reason why we're using postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script
all right let's go back and what we're
going to do is we're going to change the
value so we're going to hit send here we
are we see all of our movies using the
get command now what we're going to do
is we're going to use a look filter on
just
id2 which is the irishman so do slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record in our array
and so
we can go ahead and do that
and we're going to use the uh delete
command to actually do that so
we'd be able to
push um
in a
record we've been able to
view records filter guide games records
now we're going to go ahead and do
delete and so we can do app delete and
then we're going to filter by
specific id number
and when we do this we'll actually then
uh when we put in the url path which
will be localhost code 3000 slash movie
slash and then the id number so this is
inside that one or two probably use two
that will then
uh delete from
our array
the record for the irishman
[Music]
i do the shortcut add a keyboard drop
out of control press s
to save files on
windows or command plus s on my mac
and
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying that the movie has
been deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and
let's just check our code
good save our file
and we want to rerun
the
index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to postman
and grab
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie id and then we'll delete that id
okay so we went against the argument
then we hit send
and there it is
now we're going to change
the command to delete
so we hit
1 will actually delete conception
movie has been deleted it's great
and let's go ahead and
grab our use get to
pull in all the movies that
are listed and it's not going to find
movie number with the id1 it's not there
anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the irishman and so our delete function
has worked
there we are so we've installed express
we're using express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
port 3000
we are using express
to pass the json
effectively back and forth we have a
simple array that array is then being
used to create an api to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie then search for a movie a
filtering against an id
and then
we can actually finally go ahead and
delete a movie
all this using express.js
today we're going to be covering node.js
authentication using jwt or json web
tokens so let's get started so
why are we going to go down this path so
let's cover the key things that you need
to be asking yourself such as what is a
json web token
what is the value of using a json web
token and then what does the actual
structure of the jwt look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts uh both
in the enterprise and uh
in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a jwt
using express and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
json web token
so a json web token is actually based on
an open standard and it's one that you
can actually go ahead and research
and it allows a
definition of a compact self-contained
way of being able to securely transmit
information between parties using a json
object an adjacent object is a
javascript array and it's very compact
it's a very tight way of being able to
send data back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about jwt is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from http servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web location where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that
so for instance you may have a number of
enterprise applications that run across
your cloud environment you may have some
enterprise applications that run in your
data center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
your customers authenticate once and
then be able to have their id transition
from one to the next
jwt is a great way to do that the
content is extremely secure and we'll
get more into that in a moment but
it is the highest level of security you
can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with jwt is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to add in jwt
into your application is very very easy
to do which makes it very easy for you
to actually implement and a large scale
authentication and authorization and so
authorization is a key word there um
that's something that you're probably
coming across um a lot instead of just
being able to identify who you are we
want to be able to authorize what you
have access to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a jwt there are several key elements um
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down
what
kind of token it is by twofold it's
gonna be a gwt token and what is the
signing of algorithm so sha 512 is a
very complex and secure algorithm and
certainly the one that i would recommend
that you use uh you can even go higher
than that but um sha 512 is a great
place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
uh so in this instance we have a name
the admin time type um sub name um just
really you can put whatever kind of
information you want in there as long as
it's applicable um to the uh service
that you're passing the data into
and then you have your
signature which is
um encoded header and payload with the
algorithm that you've sent so in this
instance it's sha 512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for jwt
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance
you have a application and you want to
be able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of the
application
jwt is a great way to be able to encrypt
that data and be able to pass that data
back and forth
examples would be jumping from different
parts office 365 and be able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a
multi-distributed environment where you
want to be able to have a way to be able
to securely transmit data back and forth
and know that that data is being
encrypted is another good example
so with that let's take a pivot and
we'll go ahead and we'll look at
creating a demo uh using our standard
stack of node.js and we'll use express
and postman
and these are tools that you may already
be familiar with if you've seen other
videos that we've created in this series
and we'll go ahead and create a jwt
token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a jwt
json web token there's going to be some
tools that we need to get started with
the node.js is the first so let's go
ahead and
find node.js at nodejs.org and you can
either download windows mac or linux
code
obviously you'd install the one that
would be for your operating system
the next tool that we want to install is
a those installed and up and running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
let's go full screen on this get rid of
the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
we're going to put this on our desktop
for right now let's go create a new
folder and we'll call this node jwt
[Music]
for json web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize
this folder for
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again and let's go ahead
and one things i love about
vs code is going to run the terminal
window right from in here so let's go
ahead and
select npm init
or he knows to pull from the folder that
we're in and we're just going to select
yes here in a second
for um
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that the packet has been
created
and there is a json packet with just
default information
about the npm package that we created
for node
and we're going to go ahead and create
an index.js file that's what we'll be
pulling from the package
and the index.js files we're going to
actually rewrite all of our code
and what we want to do right now is
install express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that we'll be able to
test our jwt
against and then we'll also want to
install
a
jwt
file so let's call this json web
token and from our terminal window we'll
just go ahead
and install both of those and do that by
typing npm install dash dash save
and then we're going to put express
and json web token
express and json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create
an express app
and we're going to use the
get http
header to
have everything go from the we're going
to actually have everything running on
our localhost and we're going to run
everything off port 3000 we'll do that
in a moment here but we'll have
everything running off a sub
folder called api it's where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put a message that
hey there to show that everything's up
and running
okay
[Music]
save that
and say if you can do control plus s to
save your files
and as you can with a lot of windows
applications and we encourage you to do
that a lot so let's go ahead and open up
postman with no i'm going to go to our
web browser on this one
and we've got postman
takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and postman again is a tool for being
able to
manage api calls and
so you don't have to write a script
so here we go
and we can go in here and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to
do a couple of things first let's let's
get everything running so we want to
listen on for port 3000 that's we're
going to run everything off of
and
in the console log we'll actually throw
in a message to confirm that we are
running on
uh everything is up and running we'll
just say okay
uh server started on port 3000
again we're going to be running
everything off localhost so you'll be
able to see this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there
and we're having everything running off
the api file so let's go and we'll type
in under our get localhost
colon
3000
like slash api
and we hit
the
there's lots of different http headers
um we can use we're gonna use get for
right now
send that
and
hey there welcome to the api service
so two weekly this is just an api we're
creating right now this is not
we'll get into that right now
all right
so we want to be able to post data
and uh post is actually pushing data in
so we're going to go into
uh going to create a login screens again
again this is all api so it's
not real but uh okay
you get the point
and then you can construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating
a
uh an array
of a random user and that they can have
a name of id one that we have users
gonna have an id value which is one um a
username value which is gonna be john
and an email value of john gmail.com
then we'll make this
a
json
web token jwt signing
and they'll have to sign with their user
and
this is going to use a secret key which
will be our hash
our hash 512
token
and
respond to the json with the token
okay so let's see now
okay and we're going to
amp dot and this will be our post
api posts
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token with it
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script
index.js
runs real quick
okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so go from one app to another app
select post
and
here in the login
we should be able to
request the token
this will be our gwt token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay
let's verify
the token so
we've gone ahead and we created the
token but now we need to as we go from
app to app we need to actually verify
the token so we're going to get an error
message if we don't verify the token
correctly
so
put in a function to verify
the token
and we're going to
create a bearer header
value
which will be
the headers
and the authorization for that
and if type of bearer header
okay i have it if it's not correct it'll
be undefined
otherwise
this part token
will be split
and we're going to require the token
for our baro token
else
sense status
403
okay so barotoken is what we're going to
be calling against
to verify our token i'll show you how
that works in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually put in
here
all right so
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the the
message forbidden if we don't put in the
code correctly so let's
double check that everything is looking
good i'm going to verify that the token
is required
okay so if it is then jwt dot verify
[Music]
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and we'll be able to
put that in as part of our secret key
and if it is successful
and put in
that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code nodeindex.js
there we go nice and fast
and
i'm going to go in and
localhost
api posts
we'll change this to post
so this one api which is the api posts
which is
up here
we'll hit send
and you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we were expecting
because we haven't been able to put in a
secret key
and
put in the comment that i've forbidden
so
as we're stepping through the code
and now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below
and we just want the token itself we
don't need the wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but
we go into
author into
our
headers
we can put in authorization
and then the value
we'll do bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely
use a jwt to pass values back and forth
across the application
okay
and we hit
authorization we select that and approve
it yep we keep authorizing so if you're
authorized and you don't get the data
okay so we have everything against the
api then we have one application which
is called api post we have another
application called api plugin and we're
able to move the data back and forth
using
our secret key in our jwt token
and we have everything running on port
3000 of our localhost server
and that's our
demo so first of all let's cover why
you'd want to go through this tutorial
so we're going to cover what my sql is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my sql and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sql well basically my
sequel is probably the world's most
popular relational database and so if
you think of relational databases that
are table driven mysql is arguably the
most popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
uh relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time and again it's open
source which is great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from small mom and pop shops all
the way up to massive enterprise global
enterprises are all using my sequel
so you know why would you want to then
take that next step of connecting
node.js with mysql what fundamentally
comes down to the basics of the
differences between the two products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications
again with mysql it's open source it's
free to use you don't have to pay
anything there are no licenses which if
you compare it with other solutions out
there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
is incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably more apache ui web is probably
more mature but my sequel is very close
behind it so it has had a huge amount of
investment this is not a solution that's
only a couple years old we're talking
about a solution that's more than 15
years old
very very structured very powerful
and you can do a lot of really good
things with it
you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database um even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and
it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and my sql
so i'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
we'll get to know js.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apache friends.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
mac os 10
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
student code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for uh kicks and
giggles so i'm gonna type in node my sql
for our source code and we open up that
folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to terminal window so we can
actually see the
scripts that we're writing we'll be
using tunnel quite a bit um in this so
for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for that package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default uh file that will be created so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create our own index.js file and
we're going to add in some instructions
into that file to actually install the
correct software from the npn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're gonna
put in the requirements for that and
then we're going to also go and require
that my sql gets installed
and
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to
install
the express and my sql environment
and as that installs you'll actually see
on the left hand side under the folder
you actually see
the files starting to be installed
so for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these clients make sure
everything is installed
so we're going to open up zamp which
allows us to go in and
view and see that everything's stored so
we have my sequencer we have a patch
installed
we can start and stop under services
with zap go ahead and do that you can do
this through toner window as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my
sql um
interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases
these are just the
standard test databases and so we have
to go ahead and create one
and so let's
get our single database connection
created
so we're going to write
const
db equals mysql
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the local host in this instance
and user is just going to be a
root user account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql uh there is no
password for the root user when you're
running it locally i encourage you to
change that as quickly as you can
because you don't really want to have a
password free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do real write db.connect
parentheses error and we want to throw
an error message if the connection isn't
good
so if we do error
we'll throw the
error message
to the log window
and
if we don't
then we'll write mysql connected
all right
and then
we want to connect that to our express
app
the next
step we want to do after we made our
connection is to go ahead and create a
database so we'll do both steps at the
same one so writing the script right now
and then we'll run the commands
uh in the terminal window so we can
actually create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
um a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database nodemysql
you could call it whatever you want um
but this is just a nodemysql
script
db
query
sql
error
throw error message
rest.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created let's go save
that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created this let's go ahead
and
do node index.js
to run that and we'll connect it to my
sql that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to node by sql
so we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead
and
[Music]
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
3 000
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porch 3000.
so let's try that again
node index.js
yep and server has time for 3000
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
and database
let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 3000 all right so by doing that
we write that command and that function
and that goes and creates our database
and we'll actually see
but we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see
in our windows so all of the work that
we're doing for creating a table for
creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js and so here we are
going to create a new table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee it's going to create a table
has the employee fields which is going
to have an id which will be an integer
that will go into auto increment they'll
have a name field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
[Music]
that will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put a db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table
created
so let's test this out
and
node.xjs
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got nodemysql so
we're connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again
yeah okay to the database this database
has the name
and because but note mysql there's no
fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and let's
run the function that creates the new
table
and then
voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
not going to
put in a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
you know employee one and when we run
that function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the lit insert the record into my
sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
let me insert into the employee table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with visual
studio code is that
it's actually providing a lot of prompts
to make it easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
receive the iphone connected and we're
grabbing the
function employee one
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee e1
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there yep
there we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and
do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command
do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
i'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console
wrong results
all right let's skip this a while
okay so
let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and it says employee details now go to
the console window in visual studio yep
there we go we have now all the packet
information including the id about jake
smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting
with between the
the browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated name
and we have to make sure we're updating
your
program record
i will show that we're matching against
id1
all right so let's run that
and
[Music]
jake smith is there
now go
and select
chase conte
colon
same slash one
we've now gone ahead and updated
the
jig
and jake smith's information
so let's click on
table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we can go ahead and delete
the record as well
so it's going to be similar to
update but i'm deleting instead
we're going to delete
the record from the employee table
equals
sorry
[Music]
and
[Music]
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been
deleted
okay
select delete
[Music]
in the employee table
that there are no entries
the one-on-one record that was there has
been deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into mysql
right from node package manager
you can create table
you can select your records
you can then update
any record that you selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this uh presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb
how do you connect to mongodb with
nodejs
and mongodb is part of the mern stack so
we're going to cover what the mer stack
is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a
probably the most popular
no sequel database out there it's
cross-platform and
very easy to scale it's available on all
cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo
but it's just a very flexible database
environment for modern
applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
what you'll find is uh
mongodb was originally written in c plus
plus and it is what's referred to as a
nosql database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo so you know why connect node.js
with mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database um
it's not uh restricted by the the
challenges of scalability that all the
uh relational databases have
it's really designed for uh building
mobile applications and websites that
scale into the millions and millions of
users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability
the performance of the database is
phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it out your solution to
the cloud you can almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site solutions in fact one of the
very first mongodb applications i built
was a multi-tenant environment and it
just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
solutions across microsoft azure aws
google cloud
etc so you know why do you want to keep
connecting to mongodb and i think
probably um one of the other areas that
probably
is often forgotten with [ __ ] is just
the concept around big data and you can
i mean when you talk about big data
you're talking about absolutely massive
massive databases and
mongodb is front and center for all of
that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so um by that it allows
you to be able to build out solutions
that can go to all modern day types of
applications and the data is actually
very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy um particularly
as there is a client called mongoose
that makes the connections extremely
easy
so you know finally let's kind of look
into how [ __ ] db is part of the mer
stag
so learnstack is a javascript stack and
it's of javascript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database express
which is your server side
http environment react which is the
solution for being able to
create your solutions on the client and
the nodejs
which actually manages the whole
environment it's really an environment
that's designed to make it very easy to
be able to build out modern day
solutions so mongodb is the m in moon
express is the e
react is the r
and node uh js is the n so again
as you start working with um some of our
other videos that we have um here you'll
be able to
see how all of these tools really
complement each other so we've done an
introduction on uh [ __ ] db
really the best thing now is to get you
out you know your hands dirty by
actually doing a demo so we're going to
go through a demo what i would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series
so
you really do want to spend some time on
the node.js video
the node.js for express video the
node.js for apis video really all of
those videos help complement the work
that you'll be doing
with this video here you'll see some
real strong correlations plus a lot of
new content as well so with that we're
going to jump into the demo
so let's do our demonstration on how to
use mongodb with node.js
first thing we want to do
is go ahead and install node.js so
you're going to go and do google search
node.js and that should bring up a
result of going to nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms
so windows linux
mac os they're all supported you can
also get the original source code and
recompile your version of node.js if you
want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install your favorite uh text editor i'm
going to install visual studio code vs
code uh it runs on all leading platforms
mac os windows and linux it is open
source you can edit it and i like it
because you can do an awful lot with it
just a lot of extensions and it's just a
great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to mongodb.com
so we can install the mongodb
so you want to go to software
community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the
download to install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder
of our desktop that we'll use for
mongodb so i already have a folder
created called demo i'm just going to
select that and then inside there i'm
going to put in node
[ __ ] db
and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code and
it's going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to
run that that's one of the things that i
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
in so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
in it for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our
node package manager it's going to
create our default package and we're
going to hit return that's going to go
ahead and start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um
settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return return a few times and
that will get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
area that's uh
gs package and there we have everything
this is just the
uh the the json package that provides
the instructions that npm would use to
pass the um the program now you notice
that we have index.js as our leading
file so we actually have to add a new
file here and we're just going to tour
this one index.js
so
we actually have a file that can be
referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in
our
default application so express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that
is included in our first line of our
instructions
and then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
and these are all part of our express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
express
phbs
and this is going to be our express
handlebars
and we're all going to
allow
insecure
prototype
access
you wouldn't normally do this but
because we're running everything locally
it just makes it easier for
you to actually get all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
our body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need
to be installed
when you're running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do mpn
install
and we do
save and this will install express
and we also have install path
handlebars
express handlebars
um
[Music]
and this is where we'll install
prototyping
and we'll also have
the body parser
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
scripts
so we're going to create an app in
express
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running off our
local port on local host on port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select
nodeindex.js
and shows us everything's running
which is good you can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use bodyparser
and we're going to encode
our request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to
mongoose among to mongodb
so body parts is going to use json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we work to if you've seen the api
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as
the uh jason
sorry the node.js node.js
for express node.js
for apis and node.js for authentication
uh before doing this video
uh we're going to
create a default page and it's going to
say welcome to the students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have
a simple action that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
okay
we're gonna put in the path and way to
get the list from
okay
all right
so here is
our basic web page that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and
pull the content from manga
so run this and open up web browser
you'll see what it looks like let's just
go to localhost
close out these
other tabs don't need them localhost
3000
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if we click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
let's begin extending our app so what
we're going to do is we want to
set
the views
and we do a
join
on our directory name
and app
engine
so let's go for our views we haven't had
pension yet but let's go ahead and
create a new folder
i'm going to call that one views
and let's expand that
actually that should be okay
hps
express handlebars
and we're going to allow prototype
access for express enterprise
so with express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with
swift for a mobile application
on the mac
using xcode is the same
principle there but for
a web application
so we're just
putting out here
some of our
default environment settings
i'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
and just checking through our code it's
looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have
a folder called models
at the root of our application and under
models we're going to put in db.js so
the dbjs file
is going to be where we put our
instructions
for our database and so here we're going
to go ahead and we're going to
require to import mongoose a mongoose is
a tool
in node.js that allows you to connect
to mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install our
local machine so we can actually test
this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student db
okay we're already already installed so
let's go mongoose.connect
and
we're going to call it mongodb
and
[Music]
we're going to run this off our
localhost
so we installed the community version
that i was just running out of our
localhost and it's going to run from the
port 27017
and we're going to call this one
studentdb
so again with our application we're
splitting out
all the functionality so if you want to
reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new a usernurl
parser
and we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay
so if arrow then we'll
send a message to the console log
and
we have either connection successful or
things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we'll do require
student
dot
model
so this will actually pull the model
we're going to create
and so what we need to do now is create
in
under models we're going to create
student.model
dot js
and this is where we're going to do
our instructions for
our student model so first thing we want
to do is we want to import
uh mongoose
express and the student model
so we've got there let's make sure we
have everything let's capture that
let's go to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
i'm going to create a new variable
called student schema this will allow us
to structure
what our model will look like this will
be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schemer is going to be full
name
and we're going to break down
our
jsons package so we're going to put in
the instructions for what
the schema would look like so
we have the type we have been required
this field is required
and
the second value is going to be email
type string
[Music]
this field is required
that's the
message error message you want to send
if
the field isn't filled out
now mobile phone number this will be
just a number
and
we're gonna have city
and this obtain will be
let's just make this a string we're just
going to try and keep this simple for
right now
and this field is required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
all right mongoose
dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
okay
okay new folder and this new folder is
going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
studentcontroller.js
let's go in and
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import uh make sure we're
running express
so express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router
so writer express.router
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have a connection to our mongodb
and
we also want to make sure that we have
connection to our student model
so mungus mongoose dot model
and our student model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over
effectively for our controller for our
student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
now render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
view title and this will pull in
the insert
student
i'm going to use
under our views we're going to create a
new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be add or edit
dot js oh hps sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
node.js manages all that for us
so
router dodge post
so this will be
our we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back
as part of our body
and there'll be an id
so we want to then instead insert the
record that we'll be creating
so again if you've been if you've worked
through the nodejs api
video
then you'll start seeing it there's some
commonalities here of being able to
insert or update a record
and we actually cover that
using just a sample json package this
really takes you to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record and this will be student
and we're going to have that full name
is going to
come from our body
and we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and uh
finally with a student city
[Music]
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
and we're going to put in
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so
let's create a new file student list.hps
so list.hvs
and here
so what we do is with tuned list that's
actually going to match then
the
controls for being able to
display the records in the database
and then we'll put
um a message if there's an error then
you know we'll put an error message
there and ask you to report the error
message
we're going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is we're going to call a function to
update
the record
and let's go ahead and we're going to
update their records
and we do the student.find1 and update
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message
to our console lot
yeah looking good
and again this is just an example
but uh something that you'll be able to
do yourself
i have with it your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to
then render
the records
all right
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
b and
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay
all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're going to do the router against id
this will allow us to
get the content
so i'll be able to give information by
id of the student
and what you can see is there's a lot of
the work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get our
view title we're going to put that into
our document
okay
all right
so our next router
is
we want to be able to
delete
a record by id
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to find our records for our
student record we're going to find it by
id
and then we'll do find by find id and
remove
okay so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
gonna redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
otherwise we'll send an error message to
our console log
okay
so i think we have
what we need
maybe there's maybe there's one more
thing i think we need to
i think this is good
okay
so
let's go to our
layouts add a new file there
we're going to call this one main layout
dot hbs
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of
our web page together
let's
write this out so i'm going to put in
html
code
and
[Music]
we're just going to keep this real
simple
header
we want a title
and this is going to be students
database
gonna maybe we just got students
so
we now go to
[Music]
we'll try and find out bootstrap
for we're going to just grab that
and we're going to use
bootstrap to get started
and there are a couple of components
there's a css component and then there's
the javascript component so let's just
go copy the
css component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of our
web page
so
and then here's an example of different
components you can create
uh if you're not used if you haven't
used bootstrap before it's an open
source framework originally developed by
twitter great tool
so
in our header
we want to
put in the link to the css
there's that
and
now i need to also
open our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on
um for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the box style that
you get with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
plus
bg info so this is actually bg info is
a css class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you have the id of box
and again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to put in
the content which we're going to call
body and this will
show up on the screen
so again for pulling from records within
bootstrap dig through bootstrap lots of
content there for you to be able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
view title
and the
um
the
the the french brackets allow you to be
able to pull records and content
directly from
the code that we're writing
so we're pulling title from insert
record and it's part of our
router
command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student
post
i'm just gonna do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field and this
will be for id
so we want to want to generate the id we
don't have somebody put that in
and then we will put in
[Music]
our
form elements
so we'll have first will be
a label
it'll be full name
there will be
an input field
this will be text in the input field
and
again we're using form dash control
which is from
bootstrap css
and we'll have
a full name
and
placeholder before name so
where we have name there
will actually match up
with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student full name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for our
remaining form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so i'm going to put in 4 as well be
email
and we'll do
mobile
and city
and
here we keep going
and final group
yeah we'll be able to have the
type of
tool for putting in mobile
so as you can see because we're using
just centered html here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
uh javascript libraries for
formatting the field that you're in
regular expressions things like that
and let's put in our final value
which will be for city
and normally when i'd be writing this
by hand i would actually be copying
pasting
sections of code and just changing the
values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here i'm just typing out everything for
you so you can
see the
whole process
okay
all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with our
records
and we want to have a button that allows
you to submit
you also want to have a button to select
view or if you want to be able to view
all the records
okay
all right looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to
pull our records so
[Music]
this will display
the list of students
in a table
all right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to
delete a particular record from the
database
i'm going to call this one
create a new student record
for student list
i'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
[Music]
an element that allows you to create
a row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull from the model that we created
earlier on so this being the data that's
been submitted so we have it put in the
value for the email full name
and mobile and city
we're not going to show id
so it's pulling out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into hps file
and
it's our list
let's bring our
file entry here
[Music]
this will be for city
then
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah yeah we're going to do is we can
add in
reference for the id
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to
delete the document
so hraf
calls
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the id
there we go
passing that instruction over
so click
[Music]
simple
i'm going to ask him are you sure you
want to
delete if somebody clicks on the record
they hit cancel then might get deleted
if they hit ok then it will get deleted
this is why you can actually write
js in line
okay
and
then we want to
close out where
the row will end so how
each opens and closes
the record
just tying up some of the html there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so
see now
we want to
also require
our model
and then
[Music]
we have our
student controller also be
a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and
this is just the instructions on where
we can actually find
the content
okay it looks good so let's do
node next js
everything's safe gonna rerun everything
and we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go in to our files
this is one that we created
so
error is in
[Music]
string controller see where's the error
oh we need to
have our much we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up [ __ ]
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
it's just installing the latest updates
here
so
we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
and that's the port
just double check that make sure we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
[Music]
there's our port and student database
and we did this with one go to mongoose
for connecting to manga
so i'm going to connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called student db
student db sbk sensitive
and collection name is
students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there yeah there's a database
and let's go we run our index js file
and everything
was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and
here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
so separate
to our
code
so there's some spacing we probably need
to add that so let's go ahead and just
add that
and
let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know
it puts in one line one space because we
didn't put in the actual html code for
green multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
smith and we do smith at
gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in a random
phone number
there we go we don't have any formatting
so we could put anything in there
and the city uh i know where am i um
this i'm in delhi so submit that
hit submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
and if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it and now we actually
start seeing our records being created
and we see the id is automatically
created and there's our records
let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
bangalore hit submit
all right city is now bangalore
and if we want to we can
add it again
and so this is
pulling in now if we do a delete it's
going to
ask us do we really want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting applying
there
and the records are all good so we can't
make that smith jones
but because we need to hit submit
wouldn't update the record
so we hit submit updates the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and
ah
it has
congrats that record okay so let's go
back about code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to
our student controller
and we'll find out delete
and you guys delete and we had
a
we had a couple of minor errors there
it's where it's good to test out your
code
okay let's run that again
and
refresh everything
so we'll go to our database we're gonna
go create a new entry
let's call this one some john john
gmail.com
and we'll put in a phone
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
[Music]
our uh bootstrap so there we are there's
john do you want to delete they say yes
yeah easy there we go
and we hit refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items and we did all of this
using
just open source solutions through
node.js and that was with using express
some of the components come with express
mongodb for our database and then
mongoose to connect to our database
so let's get started with typescript
with node.js but before we begin make
sure you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and clicked on the bell icon so
you never miss an update from
simplylearn
so we'll first look at what is
typescript
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of javascript
typescript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft
the limitations of javascript for
developing large-scale applications at
microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
complicated javascript code there was a
demand for custom tooling to make
development of javascript components
easier
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere
javascript is supported in a browser on
node.js or any other application
typescript is a javascript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
javascript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands javascript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities with additional code
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for javascript code
node.js is a javascript runtime based on
the version 8 javascript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event-driven
javascript runtime for building scalable
network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server-side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat news feeds and
web push notifications because it allows
for a persistent connection from the
browser to the server
the current coding method such as static
typing and type checking are supported
by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop server
side apps with rigorous type checking
avoiding run type errors and other
typescript benefits while maximizing
node.js capabilities
now let's see how to setup the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads
so here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for windows mac os
and source code
so go to windows if you have windows pc
and click on install
click on windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since i have
already installed in my device i'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my
system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
let's run this command and typescript
will be installed since i have already
installed typescript in my device
we'll cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and
node.js let's see
our example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into visual studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
visual studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
we'll write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log we'll call the function sum
and we'll provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5.
so let's save
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd
type.ts command
then we'll enter
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see
it's showing the value showing the
output as forty nine plus five the sum
of nine plus five is forty so we'll
delete this
and
write another program
to show a hello message or a welcome
message so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
message
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
we'll call the function
welcome
and pass
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular uh open source cross-platform
javascript programs it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the core
programming runtime and allows you to
build solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store um data intensive
applications that are asynchronous and
event driven in their model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're gonna then us be asking you
how does nodejs work well node.js itself
is actually built on the v8 engine and
the v8 javascript engine is the same
engine that runs javascript in your
chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking out through
your i o input outputs and is a single
threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing and peppering
your answers with is examples of work
that you have done now it doesn't matter
if those examples are purely
experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application is really valuable
because it shows that the person that
you're meeting with that you have
knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with js with the
practice of working with node.js
so be asked about you know you're on
essentially the i o refers to the
transfer of data in and out of uh a
system and that's really it you know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
and whether it's on a physical device
and network or files within a system
again it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front end and back
end development and this is a question
that i can ask a lot when i'm meeting
with clients um you know people get
really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved inside of your web browser or
the app on your
mobile device back end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of web application
gets run in the front end anything with
css html5 uh client-side javascript it's
all gonna get run in the front-end
everything else such as connecting to a
database um gets run behind the scenes
in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are used on
on the front end
so html css javascript those are all
common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks
backend frameworks will include java php
python and node.js are some of the
back-end technologies you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use um and this is actually
a good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you can respond is do
you mean node package manager and the
reason why you want to respond like that
is that you want to qualify their
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them
includes references to mpm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you tell me what it is you know can
you go into a little bit more um details
you know can you provide two main
functionalities and so one of them is
being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages um so you can go to like
search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution such as
express js
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
your packages very quickly through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules
in node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for nodejs and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side uh shows that we really do need to
have http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you can actually
write some code to actually then listen
on the local host port 2000 for where
you'll be running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess features within your node.js
project you have a url
module for any url passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep
your storage of files um to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back-end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
gyro it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest websites out
there such as facebook so why would you
use node.js well the first response is
kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret source with
node.js is the node packet manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so and the reason why this question
may come up is the person interviewing
you is seeing whether or not you do know
the difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a
server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript nodejs is
written in c and c plus
angular is used for building out single
single-page
client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each other
angular splits web applications into the
mvc and model view control components
whereas node.js generates a lot of
database grades it does more than that
as well but you can think of node.js as
that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is um
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one i really like working with
express.js allows me to build out web
applications really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so um here is an example of express
js which is a in itself really a
flexible budge a solution that you can
do lots with and mongoose which is a
more focused solution
which allows you know to you make it
easier to connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explain this earlier on that you
can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what's uh the pros
and cons so a pro is that node.js is
extremely fast a processing an
event-based model uh it really is fast a
con is if you have something that is a
very heavy computational task it's not
so good at that um now i will caveat
that this is that node.js is getting
better all the time and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be
calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as computationally
very heavy but what you can do in that
example is you can offload the task to
another solution that's designed for it
and use apis to pass the data back and
forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that uh
when you do a callback you may end up
doing lots of nested callbacks
if you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking to
your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's events
driven i can use javascript there are
some challenges and but what i do to get
around those challenges are and that's
where you can say that you know you may
run the complex script off and you may
write that in net or java or php and
then use an api to do the response back
into node.js so you get the benefits of
both worlds but minimize the investment
in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality with over 50 000
packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with this access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for
getting access to all that content now
con is working with relational databases
with node.js isn't as easy as a nosql
database now you can do it and there are
ways around that and what i would do
when this question comes up is always
kind of pivot to say hey this is how you
can actually then uh get around building
out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out
a con is that node.js is single threaded
and so it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution elastic environment such as the
cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command
so an example we have here is uh you can
start a variable and the variable is
going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean
so event driven programming means that
if something happens something else will
happen in response so for instance if
you click a mouse that mouse click is an
event that means something has to
respond to that event uh just think of
it as cause and effect it's just the
basic motion of physics so that's what
event driven programming means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then non-blocking input output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in nodejs so an
event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages
the classes that hold all the objects uh
within your event
and we have an example of this on the
right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown uh the functions are then called
on that event synchronously
so for instance we have in our example
on the right hand side we create an
event and then we have the functions and
that executed in a series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types
one is an asynchronous non-blocking
function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response
in a series for how the response is sent
to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package json file is at the heart of our
node.js package when we actually will
initialize a solution a folder to be a
node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on node.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out
how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic uh json collection
of pairing of
uh key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces uh what is the
version and the description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js
but index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and the response it
would would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month um and it'd be in a readable
format so it would read out as
2020 and then the month
so
what is express.js and you've heard me
mention this a couple of times in the
video we actually have a separate video
on express.js and express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
being able to install web.js is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example
you start off the first two lines
require express to be installed and the
store comes from node packet manager
then we have a simple application that
will then send to the browser window a
hello world message confirming that
express
is up and running and then the third
block of content starting with virus
server actually will define the port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081
and when you do that that will trigger
the application that will forward up the
message hello world and it's all coming
from express.js
so what are streams in node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable one stream for which data
can be read
uh the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where it is both
readable and writeable
and transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install
something like express so if you wanted
to install express what you would do is
you would just write them inside of your
project you want to go to terminal
window and write in the command mpm
install express
if you want to update the
dependencies within your node package
manager to update all of them all you
have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies and then if you want to
explicitly uninstall a dependency such
as express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use express.js
i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text by command
or text string such as in this case
it'll be hello world and that would pop
out and then the final line is to then
uh listen that if you go to a web
browser that's on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080 once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so
all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously
and scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function
and as you can see in this example
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if we get a response to an
application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function
to be able to build out and you to get
your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is repel in node.js so repple
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so rapple will perform the following
tasks the reader will be actually
passing the javascript he'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until the user presses ctrl c
twice
what is the control flow function so the
control flow function is a piece of code
that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is a
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running nodejs and will then
run the application in that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer clouds what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data
of a set of arrays and integers
and the memory allocation outside of the
v8 heap buffer class is used because
pure javascript is not compatible with
binary
data what is piping in nodejs
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with but
it does normally get used to pass data
from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them
in the back of your mind is always a
good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be
the fs dot open and that would then open
up a file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback how also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and
this is a you know it's a big problem
and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactive pattern is a concept
of non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end to end or e2e tests
the unix tests are tests that you're
actually doing your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to validate that the
code you're writing is consistently
working
integration allows you to
have tests that integrate your raw code
that you're working with in your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole system the whole interface as it
were for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are unused
uncalled fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is a middleware can you explain
the concept of middleware in
nodejs
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code
or updating and modifying a request in
response to a specific type of object
finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with node.js um there are
actually quite a lot but four of them
that you might use would be get post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any uh web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating the data
head is similar to get but also ask for
a response if there's no body content so
if you're using if you're developing an
api this would be a good one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined
source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so this node underscore emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application
and with that we have come to an end of
this video on node.js full course i hope
it was informative and interesting if
you have any questions about the topics
covered in this video please ask anyway
in the comment section below our team
will help you solve your queries thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you